You poor thing, why didn't you tell me sooner?
I can tell when you're not well, you know that right?
I can see right through you.
You can't hide anything from me, so let's keep it that way.
You have sore ears again.
I can tell because you're making a face when you're wincing in pain.
Please, let me at least try to do something because I know you are far too stubborn to
see a doctor over this.
If however what I do doesn't relieve some of the pain, you will see the doctor.
You will not be arguing with me young man when I book you an appointment.
Do I make myself clear?
Good boy.
Now, let me see what tools I can find around my room to help.
Give me a moment to prepare my things.
You however lie back on the bed.
I'll put a towel under you.
Why?
You're so silly because I'll be cleaning your ears.
Now shh, I'll be in a moment.
Mm-hmm.
We need this.
mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm
there, let's hear you
poor thing
should I get you painkillers or
or are you really putting all your faith in this older woman, huh?
alright
Let me start by using a sponge on your ears with hot water.
Don't worry, it's not too hot at all, I promise.
Pat, pat, pat, like that.
It's good, right?
You can stop me at any time if it becomes sore, though.
I'm not actually gonna force myself on you.
Not if you don't want me to.
Pat, pat, pat, like that.
The steam should actually help introduce moisture into your ear canal like this
and help loosen up any blockages you must have.
Although, ears are self-cleaning, you'd be surprised.
Obviously, they can mess themselves up.
That's why you need me, don't you?
My big man.
Pat, pat, pat, like that.
Okay, now to pat your ears dry,
because no one wants wet, cold ears now, do they?
I think it sounds like being in a wind tunnel really.
You like it?
Good, I'm glad.
Maybe I could change your mind about getting more treatment than
instead of being so at first of all.
It really does seem to be a guy thing.
Just suck it up.
You do realize we're in the 21st century and healthcare is accessible.
Well, actually, I spoke too soon.
Ignore me.
Okay, now to use some cute tips,
because you have a nice buildup that isn't going anywhere other than
to run around.
Okay, now to use some cute tips,
because you have a nice buildup that isn't going anywhere other than
to run around.
Okay, so, how do you do that?
Because you have a nice buildup that isn't going anywhere other than
intervention.
I'll spray them so they aren't too rough on your skin.
It's probably the blockages that are causing pain,
so do you feel any relief at all?
Hmm, well, I'll keep going then.
Okay.
Are you falling asleep on me?
If it's that relaxing, you do realize you can ask for other stuff in general.
There doesn't need to be a reason for me to pamper you.
I like doing nice things for you,
even if it's as small as something as cleaning your ears every two weeks.
Again, guess what?
You already know I'm more than willing to do it for you.
Okay.
I actually have some tweezers that I think will have a scraping effect,
because the Q-tips can't sleep against everything.
Wow, and I mentioned scraping.
Did you know the Romans had a mystallic spoon?
And that's how they cleaned their ears.
Just scoop it out nice and simple and wash it in some hot water.
Sorry if I'm information dumping.
I just find it really fascinating how reasonable the tool was,
and now we have disposable ones instead.
Stay still, though, for me, alright?
Okay.
You're gonna be hearing callers by the time I'm done with you.
Next, I'm going to exfoliate your ears with this cleanser,
and then use a harsher brush against them, okay?
That will truly get any oil buildup or gunk away,
and then you can fall into a lovely little nap, alright?
Thank you for trying so hard, by the way.
Don't give me that look.
I just want to show my appreciation for it.
I know that everyone will see how hard you really tried you down.
Just accept my admiration, alright?
Okay.
And we're almost done.
You go to sleep, okay?
If you find this soothing enough, then I can be silly and tap on your ears
or come up until you've dropped off, alright?
You did really well.
I'm glad I can make you feel better.
Please don't be shy to ask me this,
or do I really need to pin you down just so I can give you some lovings?
Huh?
No, stop being so adorable.
If you go to sleep, I'll wake you up shortly, alright?
Okay.